You know how it is. We put up a community post,
asking for our esteemed audience’s opinion on a
given anomalous topic, and when you give us the
answers, we make a video like this, responding
to them. It’s a perfect system - It runs like
Clockwork. Or, more specifically, like SCP-914,
The Clockworks - a fascinating safe-class anomaly
that can transform anything placed inside one of
its chambers in a number of exciting - and
sometimes terrifying - ways. We asked you,
if the device was in your
hands, how would you use it?
And before we get into some of the great answers
we selected, here’s a quick refresher on how
the machine works. When an object or entity is
placed into its first chamber, the user has the
option to select one of five settings, each of
which leads to a relatively predictable result.
First, Rough, which completely destroys the item,
often utterly disintegrating it and turning it
into dust. There is no way to repair such an item.
Coarse is a little less severe.
It dismantles the object rather
than destroys, cleanly and efficiently
breaking it into its component parts,
often in a manner that would be
conducive to the object’s reconstruction.
1:1 is a setting that replaces the
object or entity with something
similar, usually in size, weight, or quality.
Fine is a setting that improves
the item within reasonable means,
rarely straying into anomalous
territory with these improvements.
And the most mysterious and volatile setting
of all is Very Fine, which improves the item
or entity in an unpredictable, anomalous
manner, sometimes to disastrous results.
Great, so now we’re all caught up.
We’ve handed you a great power.
Now let’s see if you can handle
it with great responsibility…
Sam Rosenthal said, “I feel like it would be
interesting to put a musical instrument like
a piano through it on 'very fine.'. It would
be interesting to see what the machine would
consider to be an improvement with something
so subjective. Edit: It would also need to
be something very high-end, like a Steinway, so
that it didn't just come out as a nicer piano.”
Putting a Steinway piano into the Clockworks
on the Fine setting would likely result in an
improvement, making it a finer instrument
with a sweeter, richer sound. However,
putting it into the machine on the Very Fine
setting would be more likely to make the piano
come alive, turn its legs into limbs
capable of functional locomotion,
and as for it’s keys, they kinda
already resemble teeth in a weird way,
so we’re going to say that’s a no-brainer.
It’s keys are definitely turning into actual
teeth that are dripping with deadly venom.
Anyone else getting Super Mario 64 flashbacks?
Isaac Ealey said, “If most of the
chains binding SCP-2317 have snapped,
then presumably there is remnants
of the chains laying around.
The foundation could combine this
material with regular chains and put
it on very fine in SCP-914 to create new
ones to restrain the devourer of worlds.”
Something that’s extremely important to
remember is that the results of a Very Fine
transmutation are always unpredictable.
Upgrading the chains may result in them
literally gaining a mind of their own and
trying to imprison the known universe.
And if they do simply become better
chains, actually fixing them to the
Devourer becomes the next issue. Personally,
you’re welcome to take care of that one first…
Eddiember said, “So I had a crazy thought. I
would put the Substance Produced by SCP-153
(the soul extractor) through on 1:1. I'd
be interested to see what the Clockwork
would quantify as the equivilent to a soul. I
think it would be different depending on the
personality of the Soul insert, like while
one person may give their soul for love,
another one may give their
soul for a Chocolate Bar.”
Well, if the scientifically dubious
1907 metaphysical experiments of Duncan
MacDougall are to be believed, souls, despite
being ephemeral, weigh roughly 21 grams.
If the Clockworks have a difficult time
qualitatively judging the value of a human soul,
perhaps it would provide a vaguely
valuable item that weighs roughly
21 grams. Little heartless, sure, but what can
you expect? It’s all cogs, gears, and pulleys.
Shain said, “I would be interested in what
would happen if you took a drawing of Scp-096
and put it on the 1:1 setting, would it turn
into a realistic photo? And if yes then could
this trigger the shy guy to attack you? I
would also check this the other way around
to see of you could get a pic of Scp-096
that doesn't activate his killing spree.”
While it’s impossible to know for sure, we
personally wouldn’t risk this one. A single
photon of SCP-096’s face is enough to activate its
rage state, as the failure of Dr. Dan’s SCRAMBLE
Goggles proved, so even if the Clockworks produces
an even half-decent true representation of 096,
looking at it will give you a
truly horrifying death sentence.
Alek B said, “I would actually somehow get a
part of 682's body mass, and experiment on it.
Maybe downgrading the 682 piece by piece
wouldn't let it combine together again,
or maybe just upgrade, downgrade or
let some parts of 682 as they were,
maybe 682 wouldn't be able to adapt
to this. (Not a big chance tho).”
Anything involving SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy
Reptile, is going to be unpredictable, by the very
nature of the cantankerous lizard itself. The big
issue with trying to downgrade 682 piecemeal is
that each part would be likely to reform and adapt
before you had a chance to process the rest of it.
Xwingknight said, “What happens if you put one
pill from SCP-500 on very fine? I would recommend
against any more because they are not many, but
maybe it would duplicate the pill because I don’t
know how you’d improve it as it already cures
literally anything. Or maybe do it on rough to
see if it gets broken down to its components
and see if it can be reverse engineered!”
All we know for sure about SCP-500 and
SCP-914 is that, on the “Fine” setting,
it results in SCP-427, a locket with rejuvinating
properties. The Foundation are reluctant to do
any tests on SCP-500 given how valuable
they are and how limited the supply is,
but the Very Fine setting could result in
something amazing. Maybe a doctor capable
of curing anything - You know, the kind
of doctor that SCP-049 wishes he was.
MrArthur said, “It would be interesting to put the
researcher that presents the SCPs on "very fine".
Maybe the machine will make the researcher into
one of the writers of SCP-001 The databases.”
Wait you mean…me?! You want to put ME in that
thing?! Oh you definitely don’t want to put me
in the machine at the Very Fine setting.
We’d suddenly be capable of putting out a
new video every few minutes. It’d destroy your
timelines. And even if you unsubscribed, you’d
still see the videos. They’d just keep coming.
There is no escape. SCP Explained is Eternal!
There is no escape! There is no escape!…
Dr. Veronica said, “Aaaaah, it happened,
my request to be hired as a doctor
at the Foundation has been accepted.
How about taking SCP-458, the Never-Ending Pizza
Box, and putting it through on Very Fine? I
imagine that may be able to turn it into something
that can infinitely reproduce any food you desire.
Failing that, maybe put a politician
through on the Very Fine setting.
Will that make them a very fine politician, or a
very fine person that happens to be a politician?
Or will it make them Senator
Armstrong from Metal Gear Rising?”
Pizzas and politicians, the two Ps of conflicting
emotions. Putting SCP-458 through SCP-914 might
result in it turning into an entire pizzeria,
that gives away perfect pizzas at no cost.
They’ll have wonderful service, impeccable
atmosphere, and always remember your name.
They’ll even give away free breadsticks and
exquisite garlic bread bowls for the tables,
along with discounts on the finest mid-tier
wine you’ve ever seen. It’d be divine.
The politicians, on the other hand, could
go in one of two ways. Maybe they’d become
a true champion of the people - Guided by
ironclad principles that they’ll fight tooth
and nail to see actualized, doing right
by their voters and the general public,
treating their office with dignity
and poise. Or they’ll be the most
incredible silver-tongued, self-serving,
conniving backstabber you’ve ever seen,
endlessly devoted to winning office
in order to monetize their position,
raid the country’s coffers, and run off with a fat
bag of swag while the nation burns behind them.
Oh wait, you said Very Fine? Chances are they can
shoot lasers and are maybe fifty feet tall, too.
That’s just the kind of thing you need to expect.
George Simonovich said, “If you put
SCP-1609 through on the fine setting,
maybe it would restore it to its chair form.”
That is a possibility, but given the anomalous
nature of SCP-1609 - the vengeful Remains of
a Chair - it’s equally possible that it
might just become higher-quality woodchips.
Perhaps mahogany? Ooh, that’d be real nice…
Gustavo Abate said, “If you put 2 or
more things, would they fuse into one?
If they do, would the machine separate
them back if programmed right?”
I don’t believe that SCP-914 would fuse
multiple items or entities that are placed
into its chamber, you may be confusing that
with another anomalous technology - like, say,
a teleporter. But if a researcher is willing to
step into SCP-914 with a fly, then we might be
able to see for ourselves whether we’re right…
Stupid People said, “I think it would be
interesting to put one of SCP 978’s photos
through the “fine” or “very fine” settings.
Preferably one with an interesting desire
depicted, like the shy guys desire to not exist.”
It’s unlikely that even the Clockworks would
have the ability to tangibly change reality
based on the photographs of the Desire Camera.
However, on the Very Fine setting, the photo will,
at the very least, begin to move, and
heck, maybe something will even crawl
out. That’s when you’ll really regret
putting any photo of SCP-096 in there…
TheGCGamer YT said, “I would insert a cake or
some other type of food on the very fine setting
to see if it would come out as a better version
of that food, like a cupcake into a full cake or
better quality ingredients. Maybe it would simply
change the flavour and we’d find out that there’s
some kind of sentience behind the Clockworks
allowing it to have an opinion on flavours.”
On the Fine setting, everything you’ve
just described is likely to be correct.
On the Very Fine setting, on the other
hand, the cake may grow giant spider legs,
start spewing noxious amnestic fumes, and begin
attacking anyone who isn’t brave enough to eat it
and end its reign of delicious,
well-frosted terror. Happy Birthday…
MouldyDorito said, “What about Y-909 from
SCP-3000 on very fine. Interesting to see
an improved amnestic effect or perhaps
it changes the substance completely. Also
interesting if you put it through on
rough or very rough to see the output,
probably just a weak anaesthetic
or perhaps just rat poison.”
On Very Fine, the Y-909 amnestic might become
so powerful that just looking at it will induce
a permanent Alzheimer’s-like state in its
victims, effectively deleting their minds.
On Rough, it may just break the vials it’s
stored in and spill the liquid everywhere.
Darkmega5 said, “I’d print out a meme, put
it in on the fine setting (very fine might
have unforeseen consequences) and post whatever
comes out for massive amounts of Reddit karma.”
It’s an honorable plan. We do it already, in our
own way. Whenever we finish a video, we run it
through SCP-914 on Fine, just to make sure it’s
at top quality. And once, we did it on Very Fine.
We’ll let you speculate as to what
video that was down in the comments…
Braydo said, “I’m actually kinda interested to
see what would happen if we put Keanu through
the machine on very fine. Would it just break?”
Oh, Braydo, how can you improve on perfection?
Solrex the Sun King said, “Put my character
sheet for D&D into it on very fine and just
see what happens. Just uh, make sure the alignment
is changed to neutral or better before doing so.”
On Very Fine, it’s likely that SCP-914
would ignore the content of the paper
and instead mutate the paper itself. Perhaps
it would turn itself into a deadly paper plane,
flying around and blasting little paper turrets
and air-to-surface missiles at its targets.
And that might veer a little more
into “Chaotic Evil” territory.
Davon_gaming said,
“I feel like putting in one of my model tanks
to see how it looks in the very fine setting…”
It’s unlikely that those model
tanks would remain models for long.
They may wind up full-sized, fully autonomous,
and chasing you down the Foundation halls,
firing lasers and radioactive payloads. They might
even receive air support from the paper plane.
Riley Mushill said, “What happens when
you put water in and set it to Very Fine?
Would it become water from the Fountain of Youth
or would it be the best tasting water ever?”
On Very Fine, the water may become a
nightmarish, aggressive creature that
actively seeks out and destroys its human victims,
like SCP-3280, also known as After The Storm.
Though if we’re extremely lucky, maybe
life-giving anomalous water is in the cards,
we just don’t like to be overly optimistic
these days. We’ve been burned too many times…
Wildnite Studios said, “I would input the
tickle monster in it and turn the setting to
fine allowing the tickle's monster's
power to make SCP 682 docile forever.”
While it’s too much of a risk to ever
try putting SCP-999 into SCP-914,
if things went well, 999 may become so powerful
that we’d never experience sadness or anger on
earth again. And after everything we’ve been
through, wouldn’t that be a nice reprieve?
Joey Rohlf said, “I would put in one
of the 05 council on very fine setting.
Then they would make better choices
because they’re better than before.”
Don’t let them know we said this, but personally,
we don’t think the members of the O5 Council
should be getting any more anomalous superpowers.
Aren’t they ambiguously dangerous
and powerful enough already?
Dysfunctional Dragonborn said,
“I’d put an NFT into it on very fine and
hope it turns into something of value.”
Doing this might make their insidious power grow
even stronger. Rather than worthless JPEGS,
they might instead become a rival group,
The NFT Foundation, which - instead of protecting
humanity from evil - instead decides to display a
level of evil that rivals even the malice of the
Scarlet King. It’s really not worth finding out.
ChosenMosin said, “I’d put my
resume in, turn it to very fine,
and see if I can eventually
get hired in my college town.”
This is a high-risk, high-reward move. Putting
your resume in on Very Fine may make it a document
that immediately, anomalously convinces potential
employers that you would be the perfect candidate.
It may push things further, and make your
prospective employers obsessed with you.
They follow you home and watch you through
your windows. They wish to take care of you.
They wish to be wed to you.
They will never leave you alone.
After all, it was an excellent resume.
Swagger said,
“I think putting Hideo Kojima in the very fine
setting would show something very interesting.”
If you run Kojima through the Clockworks on
Very Fine, he might even be powerful enough to
design and release Silent Hills on his own.
No, we’re still not over that. Is anyone?
Hearth Fireheart said, “A titanium
prosthetic arm put in on very fine.
Predicted result of possible prosthetic arm
with anomolous properties, or an enhanced
titanium prosthetic that can move exactly like a
regular arm, while granting enhanced strength.”
We’re always down for super-powered
robot arms. Chances are, on Very Fine,
it might even get shapeshifting or immensely
powerful reality-warping abilities - So powerful
it may even begin to change the rest of your
body. Picture what happens to Tetsuo in Akira.
Bunger said, “Put a burger on
the very fine setting I'm very
curious as to what would happen to
something as simple as a burger.”
All we’ll say is, we definitely don’t recommend
eating the burger after you’ve run it through.
It may wind up eating you from
the inside once you’re done…
Deez said, “I would put raw steak in
the machine and put it on “Very Fine”,
that way the steak will taste
very delicious and be very fine.”
I’m beginning to sense that people were just
getting hungry when they started sending these
ones in. And we definitely don’t think
you should put a steak into SCP-914.
For all we know, it might turn it
into SCP-058 and get us all killed.
Nicholas Lau said, “Alright, this'll sound
disgusting. I toss in a jar some of my own
toenails, hair, dandruff, spit and
tears. Then, cover the jar in lead paint,
put on a sticker saying "WARNING: RADIOACTIVE
MATERIALS" and come in with a hazmat suit and
a lead shield. Put on Fine, then evacuate
the room for the object to appear.”
Well, that’s one of the most revolting answers
we’ve ever received here on SCP Explained.
Well done, Nicholas. It’s going to be a while
until we can get this thought out of our heads.
This is the exact opposite of “Very Fine.”
Ray Parenteau said, “A
Nickelback CD on Very Fine.”
Just like we said for Keanu earlier,
how could you improve on perfection?
And there you have it, folks. Thanks again
to everyone who sent in their fascinating and
disturbing answers. If you want to be in the next
video like this, keep an eye on our community tab.
And thank you for your continued support
- You’ll always be Very Fine to us.
Now go check out “How To Actually
Beat SCP-3008 The Infinite Ikea”
and “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture of Shy Guy
in Space? The Shy Guy Questions and Theories”
for more of the weirdest and wildest
responses from the SCP Explained community!